computer algorithms today are performing
incredible tasks with high accuracies at
a massive scale using human-like
intelligence and this intelligence of
computers is often referred to as AI or
artificial intelligence AI is poised to
make an incredible impact on our lives
in the future
today however we still face massive
challenges in detecting and diagnosing
several life-threatening illnesses such
as infectious diseases and cancer
thousands of patients every year lose
their lives due to liver and oral cancer
a best way to help these patients is to
perform early detection and diagnosis of
these diseases so how do we detect these
diseases today and can artificial
intelligence help in patients who
unfortunately are suspected of these
diseases and experts physician first
orders very expensive medical imaging
technologies such as fluorescent imaging
CTS MRIs to be performed once those
images are collected another expert
physician then diagnoses those images
and talks to the patient as you can see
this is a very resource intensive
process requiring both expert physicians
expensive medical imaging technologies
and is not considered practical for the
developing world and in fact in many
industrialized nations as well so can we
solve this problem using artificial
intelligence today if I were to use
traditional artificial intelligence
architectures to solve this problem I
would require 10,000 I repeat on an
order of 10,000 of these very expensive
medical images first to be generated
after that I would then go to an expert
physician who would then analyze those
images for me and using those two pieces
of information I can train a standard
deep neural network or a deep learning
network to provide patients diagnoses
similar to the first approach
traditional artificial intelligence
approaches suffer from the same problem
large amounts of data expert physicians
and expert medical imaging technologies
so
we invent more scalable effective and
more valuable artificial intelligence
architectures to solve these very
important problems facing us today and
this is exactly what my group at the MIT
Media Lab does we have invented a
variety of unorthodox AI architectures
to solve some of the most important
challenges facing us today in medical
imaging and clinical trials in the
example I shared with you today we had
two goals our first goal was to reduce
the number of images required to Train
artificial intelligence algorithms a
second goal we were more ambitious we
wanted to reduce the use of expensive
medical imaging technologies to screen
patients so how did we do it for a first
goal instead of starting with tens and
thousands of these very expensive
medical images like traditional AI we
started with a single medical image from
this image my team and I figured out a
very clever way to extract billions of
information packets these information
packets included colors pixels geometry
and rendering of the disease on the
medical image in a sense we converted
one image into billions of training data
points massively reducing the amount of
data needed for training for a second
goal to reduce the use of expensive
medical imaging technologies to screen
patients we started with a standard
white light photograph acquired either
from a DSLR camera or a mobile phone for
the patient then remember those billions
of information packets we overlaid those
from the medical image onto this image
creating something what we call a
composite image much to our surprise we
only required 50 I repeat only 50 of
these composite images to plane our
algorithms to high efficiencies to
summarize our approach instead of using
10,000 very expensive medical images we
can now play an AI algorithms in an
unorthodox way using only 50 of these
high high resolution but standard
photographs acquired from DSLR cameras
and mobile phones and provide diagnosis
more importantly our algorithms can
accept in the future and even right now
some very simple white light photographs
from the patient's instead of expensive
medical imaging technologies I believe
that we are poised to enter an era where
artificial intelligence is going to make
an incredible
impact on our future and I think that
thinking of a traditional AI which is
data rich but application poor we should
also continue thinking about unorthodox
artificial intelligence of architectures
which can accept small amounts of data
and solve some of the most important
problems facing us today especially in
healthcare thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]